your Twitter handle is evil hag speaking
of which who presents your Twitter
handle it evil hag why evil head because
I like it I don't know because why sorry
why do I feel like you're my daughter
and I we got to talk about this report
card whatever
sit up straight young lady and tell me
why you're evil hey daddy now I'm evil
hag because I think I think thought hags
are I've had evil hag for a long time it
was like my personal account I used to
have a blog a long time ago called salty
sea hags dot blog spot.com where I would
write like calm like humor jokes and
stuff from the point of view of a sea
witch living in a cave okay I thought
that was funny and then I don't know why
and you were doing that I think when you
were working at NBC as a page I was
doing that when I was I wasn't a page at
that point but I was working at NBC and
and I got in trouble for it because they
were sweeping the computers every night
and they found my hag blog and they were
like we've seen we've seen too much stop
the blog but I but I continued on with
the Twitter okay all right
you